hello everyone this was round eight of
the Isle of Man open international
tournament and it was a highly
anticipated matchup
Fabiano Caruana had the white pieces
against the world champion Magnus
Carlsen and it was very interesting
because Caruana chose to play the exact
same line of the reuleaux piece he
played against Gawain Jones and although
he did achieve a pretty brilliant
victory against mr. Jones believed it
was to be expected that Carlson would
find an improvement on that game so
let's see this improvement Caruana is
white and he plays efore sorry about
that
he plays efore we have E 5 9 to f3
knight c6 Bishop to b5 so again the real
opus a6 the Morphy defense Bishop a4
Knight to f6 corona castles b5 Bishop to
b3 Bishop to c5 we have c3 b6 and now a
4 exactly as in the game against mr.
Jones rook to b8 now d4 Bishop goes to
b6 and now again with this a5 idea and I
explained in my previous video while you
can't capture this pawn on f5 so Carlsen
goes for Bishop d7 again like mr. Jones
h3 is played Carlsen castles Bishop to
e3 and this is well again have like in
the game against mr. Jones Carson goes
for rook to e8 rook to e1 here
h6 is played a knight B to d2 and this
is where Carlsen took a different path
than mr. Jones mr. Jones in this
position played he captures on d4 but
cousin played rook to e8 and okay here
we have a completely different game now
Khurana goes for g4 would ideas of maybe
g5 27 is played Knight to f1 not
preparing not light to g3 and then maybe
to f5 or h5 depending on what calls in
place Knights the d8
we have night to g3 and our c5 a pretty
standard motive in pretty much every
line of the Royal opus we have Queen to
d2 and c4 is not played this seems like
a like an anti anti positional move but
well who better to play then than the
world champion Bishop the seat
and now night 2h7 preparing Knight to g5
well maybe sometime in the future
Khurana goes for b4 and Carlson captures
seek after some b3m Poisson we have
Bishop capture some b3 and Bishop to e6
Carlson offers the exchange of light
square bishop s-- we have Bishop to c2
now rook the c8 is played and this c3
pawn is a bit of a problem for Caruana
as it's a backwards pawn you can never
really push it to c4 as it will be
captured and well it's not gonna be easy
to defend it we have a Bishop to d3
night to be 7 by Carlsen and here we
have rook eat the c1 and well you don't
really achieve anything by playing d5
here for example with our attack on this
Bishop and also this Bishop because well
Bishop captures only 3 with an attack on
the Queen and after Queen captures any
three simply Bishop to d7 and now you
you you allowed Carlson's night to go to
c5 here and this would be very good for
black so after this move we have rookie
to c1 by Caruana
not Queen to d8 displayed and well there
really isn't a good way to defend this a
5-1 as now it's detect twice you can't
really defend it with rook to a3
so if black would capture Knight
captures on a5 play rook sita a one with
a double attack on the night and also
well i'm this a6 pawn because Knight to
b3 simply wins the exchange for King to
rook and the Queen so after this Queen
to d8 a karmana played Queen to b2 and
Carlsen snatch the pawn Knight captures
on a5 we have Knights to d2 by Caruana
and we have d5 this was an amazing move
as now well when the pawn was on d6 it
well
this dark square Bishop of Carlson on a7
didn't really have any any future here
so now that this pawn is on d5 here the
center will be broken and when this
Bishop comes to b8
this will be an extremely powerful piece
so Khurana plays rook to e1 and you
don't really want to capture for example
D captures on e5 again
because Bishop captures only three and
after F captors me3 Knight to g5 this
will be well this will be a much better
for black and not attacking well h3 here
threatening to capture on e4 Queen to b6
is an idea here so after this
sorry about that after this d5 move
Caruana played rock back to e 1 and we
have Bishop the b8 and now this Bishop
is a pretty pretty terrifying piece we
have it captures on d5 Bishop captures
on d5 and our Bishop to f5 and here
karana was already very very long time
and cross and played worked the c6 but
he could he could have even played a
capture sandy 4 and now karana is forced
to capture this light with the bishop
and h7 he can't really capture the rook
Bishop captures on see it because you
get D captures on e3 and you lose two
pieces for the rook
so after this Bishop to a5 move constant
didn't play you capture some before he
played route to c6 and we have Queen to
a3 now with a double attack on this
night 1085 nice to b7 is played and we
have rook a to d1 now
Carlson plays a capture 74 Bishop
captures on d4 in now Carson plays
Knight to g5 threatening ideas like
Knight captures on h3 Caruana here plays
c4 and Carlsen plays rook captures
anyone with check
we have rook captures anyone and now
Bishop to e6 Carlsen wants to leave this
row captures on h3 idea to stay a threat
and well here corner played Queen to e3
and this is actually the move that cost
corner the game although he can continue
continue to play this out for example
with Bishop captures on e6 but this
would be a much better position for
Carlsen as this a pawn will be will be
very strong when he starts going down
the board but corona played a queen to
e3 and this allowed Carlsen to finish
the game well in great style as this
Bishop became very powerful and he got
to be 8 now place Bishop f4 and in this
position karana resigned the game what's
the idea well you can't really capture
the bishop if you capture Queen captures
on f4 you get knife captures on h3 that
threat that Carson was saving now Forks
the king and the Queen and on Bishop for
if you play something like Queen to d3
this is a forcing variation that also
wins the game you play B captures on c4
now attacking the Queen Queen to e2 and
now Bishop captures some d2 and now you
get the same trick but from a different
angle
Queen captures somebody too and now
Queen captures on d4 and again Caruana
is down a piece if you capture the Queen
Knight to f3 check for to the king the
Queen and the rook and after King to g2
is simply capturing the Queen and this
is completely winning for Carlsen so
after this Bishop for Caruana resigned
the game I didn't watch the entire I
didn't watch the stream so maybe his
time even ran out as he was a very very
long time
but yeah it was a very decent game by
the world champion Magnus Carlsen and
well they they named him the man of the
island as this is the Isle of Man
tournament and he's clear he has clear
first place with 7 points and while he
Cara Nakamura has clear second place
with six and a half points and tomorrow
I believe Magnus Carlsen Hikaru Nakamura
will be deciding the faith of this
tournament as well one of them will
truly become the king of the island or
the man of the island either way so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and I would like to thank Kenneth
Johnson and Errol Eskenazi for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it and what do
you think was the reason Carlson is
playing so well in this tournament some
say that this is the first time that he
brought his girlfriend to the tournament
with him that this might be the reason
of his exceptional play so I'm
interested what do you think and yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here one of the videos will be
as brilliant victory in this line
against mr. Gawain Jones and yeah that's
it thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon